the discipline of biochemistry was
invented by the drinks industry why
because the Danes Carlsberg couldn't
make as good a Pilsner as the Germans so
they employed scientists to work out why
they couldn't beat the Germans and the
scientists said ah because there's some
there's an acid difference in the in the
water we're using in Denmark compared
with Germany so they worked out how to
measure acid at acidity that's called PA
and that was just to make better beer I
got one of them into into imperial and I
said look I could replace alcohol and he
said yeah that's great we all know that
and I said great well why don't you go
back and tell your boss you know we'll
work together and replace alcohol then
the marketeers say no there's no money
in it and there isn't because I've got
history the cheapest way of making
profit what we need is the culture to
accept it and actually to drive it if we
if the same amount of money was put into
replacing alcohol which kills it's
killed as many people this year as Kobe
it has been put into curing covid we'd
all none of us would we needed to drink
alcohol next year that the problem would
have been solved in the last year